tutti ragazzi e poi venuti a questo
video sono fa vj ci siamo dati su pil
in realtà queste qua non sono poppe è
che i ragazzi sto registrando questo
video nel mentre che ho la febbre e non
si sa per quale arcano motivo in questa
posizione qui io la febbre la sento di
meno tanto sono sexy sono un fico va beh
iniziamo più rock swing blues e ragazzi
tutti a volte ho fatto il rock swing
quelli più primi livelli di happy with
sono stati li pone una figata
magari a yo yo lancio la roba mai visto
un rock swing così figo non vederlo
proprio mentre sto conciato così forte
se gara e lo stesso mai e di bello sono
più reattivo io mentre sono cominciate
in questo modo effetto testata a caso
adesso ragazzi voi non lo sapete ma edy
ha preso la patente quindi son cazzi
stravincendo ragazzi che i primi rock
swing che ho provato
erano venti volte più difficili di sta
roba non so perché imposti col 80 per
cento e dai carichiamo c che ci stanno
sodomizzando ragazzi ma io sono indiana
jones
no no no no no no non è mai possibile e
non c'entrano ormai il col buco in pose
frase molto ambigua e ragazzi che attrae
e dai zio non ho mai tenore c 6 c 6
mogol di cui la metà come ho fatta
morire così bello bravo ho vinto il
cuore lì ma che cazzo fa ma perché ma
perché e sarà che ho la febbre legale
tutto è calcolato allora senti ho capito
che il buco non lo centri cielo troppo
grosso e non entra nel buco il
personaggio è il personaggio ragazzi
l'impossible più impossibile si è fatta
verità 45 minuti di che cazzo è va bene
così bravo grazie grazie mille giacche
che sto male almeno almeno fare livelli
belli pop swing imposti con dai facciamo
questo va bene così va bene la your self
devo lanciare il nonno ciak fontana
allora vado al contrario
beh ho fatto centro no è terminato i
ragazzi ce la posso fare
cos'è starò di che cos'è ginnaste vite
parallele
bravo non fai capire che sei ancora tu
il boss di è prevista come fisicamente
possibile questa cosa che appena
successa non fatemelo capire ma porca di
quella barca labbra ed ai e così ho
vinto sono mark player sono mark player
ho vinto nono amal player e lui in un io
sono fra i j
grazie grazie mille lo prendo come
mostra complimento mi chiamò un volto
serio dio mio
[Musica]
io non sono che cosa li faccio ancora
faresti livello era stato ormai la pro
agyness ha superato anche le mie tette
un livello decente diverso proviamo
questo press
welcome to rock e folk che bello che c'è
il greenstream così posso mettere i miei
soliti pony ragazzi i pony rendono tutto
possibile perché se non ci fossero loro
ecco qua grazie ragazzi dai croccantini
poi ti poni mangiano i croccantini non
lo so
va beh non mi faccio questi problemi
formula 1 no vabbè bellissimo fermi fra
infatti segue ci passo sopra perché io
posso io posso ai sommi e morto mi
spiace bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
lo guarda sorpasso wired sorpasso di
schumi è la madonna ferrari scuderia
io ci sono completamente sopra ragazzi
non avete mai visto una formula 1 così
[ __ ] dita verità skype vodafone cosa
phillips ma ora merda scherzavo
non ci credono superato così ci credo se
vincono i sì mi incazzo ma dai come
ragazzi è una gara truccata
guarda come sono piegato e sempre un
piacere vedere zlatan tra un livello e
l'altro ragazzi tra i to survive sopra
vi sono coniuga l'olio calore a turni
pupina fava un'altra volta grazie stato
bello dove vado non calca insomma è va
bene vita che violenza non so se è messo
peggio lui o io adesso decidete voi voi
la madonna ecco bravo premi telo tu quel
lurido dorga impossibile non si può far
sarò non è che posso sta qua tutta la
vita e che cazzo
o se muoio adesso mi girano le palle
cos'è cos'è the human centipede cos'è
sta roba a [ __ ] anni il livello per
morire come un idiota va bene così ciao
paper world che mi calmo o una donna mi
un livello tranquillo più isis ci sono
le matite c a matita o già superato una
parte che secondo me era impossibile
amiche tranquillo svenisse tornato
bambino ma come mi ha scassato il
marocco era un livello così bello prima
che vista sale miss cassa se le balle
ragazzi già le carte inutili mi da sui
nervi in una maniera incredibile
perfetto posso saltare prima che caschi
perfetto ok a posto
sono vivo da vivo non ti tutto ma
neanche se muoio lurido yannick da ria
eccolo qua bella hai rotto il coso della
playstation quanto mi dispiace e yannick
e yannick se solo tu non facessi sti
livelli della minkia ragazzi tutti a
twittare con l'austria che amo gianni
morandi sul profilo di yannick di al
qarara forino neanche italiano che
questi livelli qua ragazzi li amo
qualcosa mi dice che dovevo prenderlo ve
lo zio carlo preso preso e svenne gran
botta grazie luke grazie mille guarda ti
regalo un braccio quanto sono bravo
ecco the perfetto prendi anche il piede
quelle sono converse e portate la causa
non so perché gli pellicola d'abilità
piu i ragazzi a me piace è la roma
sembra un bambino ma non so perché mi
piace un sacco hard boltro hard ma che
hard zio ma che hard che mi che ho fatto
qualsiasi boltro nella vita non al quale
la morte è ferma a caso minchia che
botta di culo si incriccato il coso meno
male perché ci prova che ci prova
vai su vittoria zio vai su vittoria
forza debutto tutte avuto tutte ho vinto
vinto è ragazzi credo di dover andare su
tutte e due le vite non ci credo
timori se la madre è impossibile c'è
questo è veramente impossibile
niente dove il cane due vittorie invece
che due morti ho vinto ho vinto ma
[ __ ] vinto ho vinto tre volte pure
mai mai mai mai no no non ti ammazzo le
famiglie brava no ma porca ladra
ditemi voi se sono andato tre volte
sulla stessa vita tre volte c'è lavoro
ti sa che la sorella per la vittoria
vittoria di tre vite si ok basta vinto
tre ore per fasto livello basta così sei
dentro youtube am easing così no che
figo a quanti dislike justo video this
video is boring ma perché anche più i
soli haters faraday per noi tutti
stupidi animation shaw moore non l'abbia
finissimo country italico e fa sapere
che sono in italia ha già perché tutti
fanno è thing scusate è vero c'è una
ragazza e geniale sta cosa non so chi
l'ha fatta da un genio parte che non mi
carica il video quindi reale al 300 per
cento se questo è un video su youtube
dentro il video su youtube c'è questa di
youtube section ha sete bella se
scopriamo il tasto iscriviti c'è cioè
ragazzi premete iscriviti sono avete
fatto che dobbiamo stuprare il tasto
anche che mi piace vai così d'accordo
ragazzuoli proviamo a fare i livelli su
di me fa vj la fine a madonna
apocalittico chiamavi il world trovo
frate facevi prima genio ne sto
scherzando fai come cazzo ti papa vj
perso sì illuminati banana joe
illuminata e già questo video l'ho fatto
io lo fa l'ho fatto no proprio no jafari
benvenuti poco illuminati combatti gli
illuminati fino ad arrivare alla fine va
i fari a stento un illuminato con
l'arpione questo è un illuminato mi
sembra più una cappella punta poi fa vi
ci sei quasi grazie a dio e kamikaze
bravo papi gay ha salvato la razza porca
[ __ ] so morto papi j ha salvato la
razzano ciak questo somiglia a mio padre
come non è così vecchio perché ovvero
cristiano fa vince vuoi guidare dai
proviamo l'ultima in assoluto perché
vuoi vedere come cazzo si guida bella ma
che sia la macchina più bella vi abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia vita non so
come tu abbia fatto a farla ma è
bellissima che sta sta a macchina come
questo sta bambino e ci siamo e deve
bacon prime costa macchina qui cosa vi
aspettate
l'accordo ragazzi credo che i miei
livelli giorno dopo giorno acquistano
del disagio come è scritto fa vj zio di
miss e ti devo uccidere fanno sapere
subito grazie
ragazzi conclude l'episodio spero che
video vi sia piaciuto sono rimasto così
grazie a dio infatti ho sentita poco la
febbre ed è una cosa molto strana prova
beh spero che vide vi sia per cento
ragazzi cose video che cito accertamento
è un mi piace
sì ma stai calma zia che sto concludendo
fa vuoi concludere tu fai tu fai tu
adesso fare un passo così corso così
adesso fai tu se non parli adesso perché
sei stronzate mi è piaciuto come suoi
tracciato molto mi piace anche la pace
di facebook e come nei video fratena
descrizione degli stessi turisti non ci
vediamo subito bella ragazzi